j'ai pas l'habitude d'être en face
d'autant de gens qui vous fixent du
regard et demandent des photos
[Musique]
tout le monde l'écoutait
ton père a eu un accident
l'artiste se trouvait dans sa maison
près de carthagène lorsque tu te gaz et
une cigarette ont provoqué une explosion
qui a causé sa mort
je te rappelle que c'était aussi mon
père il faut que je me confier à
quelqu'un parce que c'est trop pour moi
j'ai le sentiment que sa mort n'était
pas un accident j'ai besoin de savoir ce
qui s'est réellement passé disons que
dernièrement il en voulait à la terre
entière tu me l'as de piqué qu'est ce
que tu fais ici moi c'est noir
le festival de musique créée par l
parole s'est transformé en tambours demi
dick retransmis à la télévision hier
cette première édition de lukasz
martinez présente el camino del farah
je crois que c'est le moment parfait
pour lancer ta carrière
dis moi pourquoi tu as brûlé mais dès
que le public voir les diaz entrer en
compétition
je suis venu ici pour trouver des
réponses et savoir ce qui est arrivé à
mon père piper mon frère
et j'ai découvert les musiques seulement
un concours tout va bien maintenant
c'est bien plus que ça
j'ai découvert et confiance en moi tout
est au losc avait atteint sûrement aux
monnaies dans le monde or ce gars là lé
jeune quitté seynois ce prénom il
s'entendait bien avec mon père
ça veut dire que t'étais au courant
pour être honnête
j'ai jamais trop apprécié au terrorisme
l'action
elle va rester non je reste sur mes
gardes
[Musique]